Photoshop AI this may be one of the most
important updates we have ever gotten in
terms of
advancements within Photoshop we have
seen tools come out over the past number
of years that have made our jobs a lot
easier when it comes to photo editing
but with generative fill and the remove
tool and the whole AI aspect coming into
Photoshop this is going to change the
game for a lot of creators out there and
it's going to create a lot of discussion
as you probably have already seen online
so what I'm going to do is talk to you
about some of the things that this can
do and what it can't do but at the same
time talk to a little bit about what
this means and where we should apply it
and when we should hold back as creators
so let's get down to it all right now I
have the recent update to photoshop beta
here there's been updates that have been
coming out every few weeks to about a
month thereabouts to sort of update this
process now one of the cool things that
I like about this is what Adobe is doing
is they are actually going to reward the
creators of these images now what I mean
by that is from the our sources out
there is that when obviously in beta
there will be no royalties paid but what
it's doing it's pulling images from
Adobe stock photos from the whole
gallery of images and they've got
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
photos but when this goes public from
what I understand stand is that those
creators that it pulls images from that
have uploaded to Adobe stock photos will
actually get some royalties out of this
now again there will be some AI that
manipulates the images so you may not
recognize exactly what's being taken out
of your photo but they are they
obviously have a database I think I'll
be doing that which is really cool
because some of these other applications
that you see online don't do that they
just pull images from the web and the
sort and they sort of like you know
bring it into your image and as a result
you have no rights anymore so if your
image is being used you can't do
anything about it but adobe's taking the
right step in my personal opinion all
right so let's look into Photoshop beta
real quick here and as we see we are in
it right now and if you go through each
of these um
pictures I have kind of selected here we
have this bar that is at the bottom
select subject remove background Etc et
cetera if you want to move this bar case
in point this is not really
explanatory but if you uh watched a
couple videos you may know this you can
actually just grab by that white uh
horizontal bar and you can bring it to
wherever you want it to go now I like
you to get it out of my image that is on
my main display because it can sometimes
get in the way especially if I'm editing
so I like to put it up here now you can
do select subject remove background and
of course you can add different things
into play but a lot of people what we're
doing now is actually removing items
that are in the image that makes it a
lot easier that reduces so much time and
I think for a lot of photographers and
creators out there this is acceptable
I think when you're totally manipulating
a person or manipulating a scene you're
into doing some sort of let's say
composite work yeah it's nice to say
that you're using AI to help with that
and I think that's always good to put
that in the comments section below or
your caption if you're posting this
online but you know for things like this
removing little subjects out there I
don't think that's a big of an issue
case in point we've got this light bulb
right here in front of this lady's face
now I like the image but I don't like
the light bulb so what I would normally
do is take the lasso tool and I would do
a Content aware field and I'll show you
what that looks like here let's do the
old way that was that you would do you
take this lasso you bring it around the
light bulb here
and then
again I'm using a trackpad I actually a
Wacom tablet or some sort of drawing
tablet would help a lot with this tool
but I would go to content aware fill
right this is what was used to be in
Photoshop now it's going to pull from
different areas and as you can see right
here it is all over the place it doesn't
know where to pull from to sort of mask
this image just pulling from the hair
it's pulling from her veil uh it's all
over and as you remove stuff it sort of
changes the images but it doesn't look
good at all right okay now let's do
General fill let's see what this does
now we're not going to add any sort of
prompt let's just see what AI does
within Photoshop will it remove this and
will it replace it with something else
let's find out it does take a while
depending on the processing speed of
course you have to be connected to the
internet on this you cannot just do this
offline so keep that in mind if you
didn't know that already and now it'll
say this Genera this generator images
were removed because they violate user
guidelines this does happen from time to
time and it could be because of the
shape okay now this I I've seen it on
skin and I'll show you that in a second
but also on shapes because it could look
a little
yeah all right so let's just type this
here remove light bulb
sometimes you have to tell it exactly
what you want it to do because it may
not know based on the shape so we'll try
that again this happens a lot on skin by
the way if you're trying to let's say
remove lines or wrinkles it may come up
with that warning and it's just more I
guess to safety precautions or whatever
may have you so let's see what it does
okay not bad kinda removed it replaced
it with a little something in the
background but we've got a few options
here right I've got a little bit of
flare coming in here so it's recreating
some sort of bokeh flare some sort of
lens flare which is interesting you get
three options here now if you don't like
any of these options actually look at
this how it's rebuilding sort of the
veil right here on option number three
if you don't like this you can actually
go right here and generate again okay
and what you'll do is you're going to
see it's kind of created another layer
here so what you'll do if you like this
at the very end is you can merge the
layers then you can edit on top of that
that's something sometimes what I like
to do is so I can do multiple layers of
editing so we're back into this again
and I can say all right
it's pretty good but not there but I
would say maybe number one here is the
closest if we look at the original image
it did a pretty good job look it's added
in all this detail here this looks
really good so what I'll do is I will
actually merge this
go to layers and merge visible so it's
one all right and then I'll do this one
more time
and let's see
actually let me make it a little bit
bigger here and I'll tell you why in
just a second because
let's see if this works without having
to add a prompt
sometimes when you actually make this
the circle or your mask too small you'll
leave a pretty definitive line that
means you're gonna have to go back in
there and you're going to have to
re-edit see again we're getting that uh
image were removed because it violates
user guidelines it means that it could
be something else that's fine so we'll
just type in here okay re move
lens flare again it's trial by error
it's not going to happen overnight but
let me tell you right now at this point
in time this is so much better than what
I would normally have to do from cloning
and all these other tools look at this
this is pretty good this is really good
already
I mean this looks pretty damn natural
if I want to say well let's just see
another option I'll do it more one more
time this is what's interesting about
this tool you know how much time this
has already saved me to just remove that
would have taken about a half hour
this is done within seconds
okay let's go back and see do we have
anything better
I mean it's pretty good as it is to be
honest with you we're now just
I mean we're splitting hairs I'm gonna
keep this I like this version and you
can give it a thumbs up thumbs down you
can tell why you like it because it
looks more like that and then I can say
okay great you know what
go to lair
and I'm going to merge visible I can get
rid of this if I want but I want to take
this portion out I can but look how much
this works
now you're going to see some of these
lines right here coming into play now
for some people that may bother them and
it may not depending on the the
resolution of your image if it does
that's where you have to go into the
healing brush and sort of reduce that or
take that out that's a little bit more
time but again where we were at from the
very beginning
to now
is pretty pretty impressive okay so now
let's move on to this other image here
now as we see we have a black curtain on
the left hand side now this was a a
beautiful vintage car that was shot in
his studio and as you know in studio
sometimes you can't have all the walls
complete as one color you're gonna have
to play around with Photoshop a little
bit now this would take a lot of time if
you were to do this manually previously
but now I can literally just take the
lasso tool again to be really finite
with this it does actually have helped
out like a Wacom tablet or some sort of
drawing tablet just to be very exact but
I'm just going to do a rough estimate
for you here and we're going to do a
general fill let's see what it does on
its own
here now look at this this is pretty
good it's matching the lighting matching
the texture of the previous wall now
again my masking of the car is 100 I'll
have to clean that up right there but
it's done a pretty good job and I've got
three different variations here
second variation has got some sort of
something back there I have no idea what
that is and the third one is a little
bit off but again you can regenerate
again if you want to be a little bit
more precise or see what else it comes
up with and you can always go back and
redo this over and over again until you
get the exact look but how much time
that saved me that's where this is
really going to be beautiful and useful
I've got it into some sort of uh door
there that looks off uh again not so
good I would say number one may be the
best right there and if I want to merge
it let's say merge merge visible
great go back into here
clean it up
General fill do it one more time
probably get rid of that seam in the
wall right there this is awesome and
again
how much time did it take me
this is what's absolutely amazing about
it all
so this is where I think the tool for me
works really really well now this works
great but as you see right here there's
a little bit of a seam that's coming
into play a little bit of a line not a
hundred percent I can go back in there
and I can clean that up but much better
than what I had previously so it's not
100 I know some
um you know channels have been showing
that it works 100 right off the bat it's
a little trial and error but this is
another image that again this was taken
with 100 megapixel medium format camera
there's a lot of resolution in this
let's see how it handles it now I love
this shot but this arm right here is in
the way
now I am going to just go Trace around
the arm
and
there was so
come back down here
and let's see where we're at with this
let's do a generator fill
you have this option now look at this
look how natural this looks
amazing this is a 100 megapixel images
it's noticed the depth they notice the
shades it added a little bit of the
branches right there and we've got three
options to play with
this is matching the wood
almost perfectly I mean this is scary
how good this is
look at this
now the third one may be a little bit
off one or two I think number two might
be the best but I'll do one more time
just to see again look what this did it
rebuilt the image based on what's around
it the colors the tones the grade on the
image and it's matching it that in
itself ladies and gentlemen is freaking
awesome by the way if you like this
video and you want to see more of this
kind of stuff subscribe and hit that
like button as well helps us out a lot
okay and we are back with another
another set here and again
most of these I could definitely use and
nobody would know the difference I'm
saying number one or number two
is right there actually I'm gonna go
with the first version right here uh on
the number two section and there we have
it how about that
absolutely awesome all right and before
we go to my next Point here's a quick
message from our sponsor meet the Cyber
15 gaming laptop from MSI check out this
translucent material design that not
only looks good but feels good thanks to
its Ultra lightweight chassis at only
1.98 kilograms give yourself the upper
Edge in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12 gen
Intel Core i7h Series processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immersed with its nahimic twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com let's get into this
let's say you take an image right and
you're like oh my crop is off like I've
got this beautiful shot of this white
tiger jumping out of the water at the
zoo leaping to get something but I've
got half of a little bit of his his left
ear cut off here and I'm going oh man
only if I could right well
let's say I want to bring this out a
little bit more and it's like okay I've
got this here right
I got to do a generative fill you can
take the rectangle
let's see what it does let's see if we
can add more to this image
and make it exactly what I want it to be
and this also helps a lot especially
when we're doing crops for Instagram you
have to do that 4x5 or 5x4 aspect ratio
because you want that picture to fill up
your screen right but you're like oh I
missed the crop I wish I had a little
bit more space and there you have it now
okay
this is option number one got rid of the
ear but it did bring up the whiskers and
it looks pretty natural this is pretty
good now again we've got some whiskers
here I can remove that if I want
that one's completely off number three
usually number three out of all your
choices is pretty much the off one here
let's just do another generation again
but look how much better this looks you
see the water you see the texture you
see the fur the depth of field it is
there if I want to remove the whiskers
right there near the ear area it's on
100 that's easy to do how much time did
this save me this is where I think the
general generator fill works really well
sort of expanding your image and
Photoshop already kind of had this with
your crop tools they were already doing
this but now it's taken to another level
how much it can actually recognize and
render it's pretty damn awesome this
okay better a little bit of that seam
there
not a hundred percent
it's not bad and then if I want to just
I'll show you what I would do with this
in case a point then I would just take
this tool
which is your patch tool
and you can play around just a little
bit so you can play
just a bit boom and remove these
whiskers and I'm gonna wear it here
sometimes the content aware works better
than uh
the normal and we're pretty much good to
go at least I have something definitely
much more usable I might want to build
this up a little bit more in this area
but again
that is a great starting point and it
took me minutes versus hours going back
to AIO again a little bit because you
know talking to a lot of my photographer
friends out there some of them are pure
some and they may be like you who
believe that hey this is cheating this
isn't what you you should be just taking
the photo and you can do a little bit of
editing with color but you shouldn't be
doing anything else you should let the
scene be as is let me explain something
there's always been editing done even in
film photography for years from dodging
and burning to cropping and I mean even
retouching things have been done and
they were done in a much more manual
process some people don't understand
this now or maybe they didn't you
weren't exposed to it back in those days
maybe they got into film photography or
photography later on in life but there's
always been some editing involved where
I do feel there is a line drawn is when
you're actually completely manipulating
somebody to be completely different
unless you're creating art and that's
when you're saying this is an art my
artistic impression of what I want this
to be that is acceptable and I think as
we as creators and photographers need to
understand that this is the world that
the younger generation is going to know
and understand and they're going to take
a pipoto and yes AI is going to get
better it'll probably in viewers time
the camera will be able to you know
compose for you get the right shot
everything that you need and it's really
about tweaking the image to be exactly
what you want it to be you'll type in a
few commands and voila you're there
photography is Art I look at it as art
and art is our impression or our outlook
on the world or how we see it and we all
see things differently
I do feel it's great to acknowledge this
in your captions and your comments and
when you're posting these things or when
you're going to display them in a
gallery for example that yes you have
used some tools to play around with but
I don't think you have to list
everything out because look
I mean you don't that's ridiculous but I
feel like if you're gonna take
somebody's face and you're going to
manipulate it to the point of
unrecognizability but you started from
someone I do think you need to give them
credit I think that's valid and if you
are going to take from other artists I
do think it's valid to give them credit
as well that's my stance on this but
I'll tell you what this tool right here
is going to change the game for
photographers and creators and when it
gets into video
it's going to be a wow holy cow it's
gonna be absolutely awesome anyway guys
those are my thoughts on the new
Photoshop AI generative fill
um a lot of great Tools in there and I
haven't shown you all of them but that's
the one that everybody's talking about
let me know your thoughts in the comment
section below if you like this video
once again subscribe to the channel hit
that like button and I'll chat to you
guys very soon take care